okay I would say it was a pretty good
night for you guys how are you feeling
yeah we feel great it feels so good and
tired we've been here since 8 15 this
morning dancing dancing dancing and it
paid off yes I mean you were just the
man who wears so many different hats I
mean at this stage of the competition
with all the shows that you do we saw a
little bit in the package how are you
feeling like both mentally physically
how are you doing oh I'm not gonna lie
physically I'm beat up but it's the it's
the uh it's the cost of doing business
right it's I wanted this I wanted to
come on the show I wanted to put in the
work I I got partnered with somebody who
wanted it as much as if not more than I
did so I'm gonna put up with my knee and
my shoulder in my back because we want
this so it's worth it
um what has surprised you the most about
working with Wayne how busy he is I mean
this guy is so busy but I think overall
just how super uber talented he is like
I I you don't really to get it until you
work with them and then you're like okay
he is the legit he is legit I mean
everybody knows Wayne Brady but like
when you get to work with him you're
like okay I see I see I'm trying to
educate her I know but I gotta tell you
I truly when I tell folks that Whitney's
my partner on the show I hands down I'm
the luckiest guy in the competition the
luckiest guy in the competition because
when you can learn from somebody
take that opportunity and next week is
the semifinals I mean what are you guys
going to do next week in order to get
that spot in into finale
we're gonna work so hard I mean harder
push harder than we've ever had because
it's game time you know we want to get
to the finale so we're going to push so
hard two numbers two numbers a uh
avini's Waltz and a Pasa doble yep and
uh we we and we got to get it in I mean
my schedule I'm doing let's make a deal
and and writing and rehearsing for the
aamas so we're rehearsing in the morning
and at night and she has her kid and and
she's building the numbers as we do like
we just finished tonight she has to have
a number tomorrow that we have to
rehearse what come on
um lastly are you gonna take any of this
dancing into your hosting duties were
they made yeah you'll have to see folks
know that when I host an award show
there's always a big opening number but
now that we've we've been doing this
maybe there'll be a little little
sprinkling of everything that I've taken
from uh from from Dancing With the Stars
and from Whitney